I think justice has been served now the
truth you're waiting for the truth and I
feel that he went to all the points and
decisions of how he got to it all five
of them came to they had to all agree
with this decision and they all did was
there any part of the ruling that
provided you with any comfort really
because it was quite gory about her
injuries again and but the whole point
was that he did use those bullets which
are devastating they crush your body
inside and anybody who picks up and uses
a gun like that can only know that
they're going to and that was one of his
main points they if you pick up that gun
with those bullets you are going to you
going to fire that gun somebody's gonna
be killed that's up to the justice
system now that's got nothing to do with
me and I really don't care how long it
is as long as he pays for what he's done
and he takes responsibility for what
happened he take responsibility for what
he's done was it more about the actual
conviction yes you you you felt
manslaughter no it wasn't no it wasn't
sufficient the judge Court is you you
heard him a human tragedy of
Shakespearean proportion yes well
they're Eva's mother you must feel
pretty similar exactly I mean he's
ruined his life like tennis my attorney
she said to me there's no winners here
there's no winners here my daughter's
dead our family is devastated living
without her and he's he's families
devastated and he's responsible for that
and finally what do you hope for the
future for Oscar Pistorius I really
don't I don't have any comment about
that
I really don't I'm just happy with you
know think of the way things win today
and I feel that we've got just as well
believer and for maybe lots of other
women now if I can help and do some work
in that direction do you feel this is
people do some closure it has in a way
it's never gonna be because we miss her
everyday we long for her everyday she
was the joy in our love and that's gone
out